hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i'm going to be
catching up on some of the trailers the
ones that i'm most excited about that
came from the game awards which was last
night i was there in person which is
awesome it's like such a cool
environment it's so exciting being there
in the room and then having the trailers
play on these huge screens with these
incredible speakers um but you
definitely do miss details for sure uh
you know it's pretty far away there are
people talking people got their phones
out it's a different experience so i
have seen these trailers but i wanted to
re-watch
um a number of them just to like get
more of an idea of the detail or see the
things that i might have missed so we're
going to watch hellblade 2 eldon ring
slit ahead which i really lost my mind
about alan wake too and star wars
eclipse were the the ones that i've
chosen here hopefully i'm not forgetting
anything uh extra um it was a fun night
no huge reveals um like i really would
have wanted and i felt like i was very
surprised by a lot of the winners um
this is the first year when i did not
guess the game of the year winner
correctly but i'm so happy for hayes
light and joseph harris uh for winning
with it takes two that was awesome um
disappointed that psychonauts 2 didn't
win anything i feel like double fine i
don't think has ever won anything at the
game awards and it's a really really
really fun game uh very happy that house
mark did win with fraternal um but of
course at the end of the day it is just
you know an award show for fun um it's
not not definitive you still get to
choose your picks for all of them
personally so we're gonna start with the
elden ring cinematic trailer
it looked beautiful i'm excited to watch
it again
and i also have decided this is going to
be the last piece of elden ring content
that i will consume at all if they
release any more trailers
i'm out i'm done it's finished i just
want to play the game at this point you
don't need to show me anything else so
this is it let's do it
i feel like i definitely missed details
on this one for sure
but when i recall i see it true
i like the way this is sort of wintry
fog
that's so pretty
it's very
zelda meets
what are the rings
and the demigods began to fall
starting about
[Music]
[Laughter]
hair the the detail on that skin
queen maricopa was driven to the brink
that is nuts how good that looks damn
[Music]
the shattering ensued a wall that
wrought only darkness
the elder ring was broken
but by whom
and why
i really like the way this world looks
very very very into it
yeah i feel like it's certainly the most
tolkien feeling
of all of fromsoft's games
[Music]
it's ganondorf look at him ah even he
has a cameo
that enemy design is so cool
they're so good at it the concrete the
stars
chaos plates kratos
these two were the mightiest
[Music]
oh my god this is cool
but there would be no victor
[Music]
nine tails
[Music]
i wonder if this will actually be in the
game or if this is just for the trailer
[Music]
unless of course
thou should take the crown
hmm
she's very interesting i don't know what
a deal is
it's a really good
trailer it is
so
good in terms of like setting the tone i
feel like
um but yeah their design is incredible
just their character design top to
bottom like you look at this
and
it just you just have to ask so many
questions like okay what is the
significance of her having this like
extra
uh like a hologram of herself what does
that mean what's happening with her eye
what's this texture on her chest
like it's just
this is amazing this design is awesome
what's what's this you know
so many questions very good trailer
super into it um and i do think i
probably want to read a breakdown of
what she actually says too
good way to get some law
um all right let's do hellblade two
i love
uh ninja theory they and she said
are wonderful
with our swords
we will forge new stories
to strike the gods that haunt us
this sounds really good in my headphones
you might see me as weak
but i will show you sound designers
[Music]
we will embrace our suffering
soothe our scars of grief it's so
gorgeous break their siege of our minds
you may see them as gods
but we will show you
what lies behind their eyes
is so curious about which parts of this
it's coming easy
gameplays
this is gameplay that looks like a
gameplay camera
to risk your own life
for what you believe is your sacrifice
to make
to lead others to death
[Music]
this is such a cool
piece to give us as well
like what a cool mission
i love the way they do the audio it's
[ __ ] healthy
those whose eyes are clouded by fear are
besieged by the ghosts that haunt them
senua saw that to win the war we must
break this siege
this is so cool it's such a cool moment
an unshakable truth
break it
with an impossible feat i definitely
didn't see that i could not see how he
looked
get ready
what's he trying to do is he's trying to
take a sleep snapping
[Music]
the barrick
oh no
the audio man
take me
it does know her name
the performance like
ugh
i don't know why i'm smiling so much
watching something that's clearly [ __ ]
up i feel like this is just so visceral
[Music]
it does look very bleak i wonder
what the surrounding environments are
there's a beach that
runs now
[Applause]
bad time for it to stop raining though
huh
oh i didn't see that either you didn't
bit somebody in half
oh my god
help me
i know you he needs you
yeah
he's not trying to kill you
um
that's interesting
help me i wonder if it's going to be
like a lost guardian type situation
um
wow i i think that is incredible um
it's official gameplay i don't know what
that means i i think that that's my
highlight of the show though i think it
looks so good the design just from top
to bottom
that whole sequence the tension the way
that um her
i don't know mental state creeps in you
know um
nah just
so so so good so potent
um very very very very into it i
absolutely loved it um
yeah and i love the first hellblade if
you haven't played it please check it
out i imagine it's probably free on game
pass so not technically free you are
paying for it but um
it's short and a very unique
game that tackles
eh how do we get into it there's also
like some things that could be spoiled
for you so don't look anything up about
it if you don't know and go and just
just jump right in wonderful wonderful
wonderful
okay let's do slit ahead they really
kind of ruined my day with this one
uh what have i done
because
this i saw silent hill on screen and i
squealed i was like
oh my god i dropped my phone
through it on the ground
inside the microsoft theater
um obviously it's not silent hill this
is slit ahead uh it is toyama um
so i'll take it i will take it
and
yeah this this ah i love horror games uh
survival horror is my favorite genre of
video game
and i intend to do playthroughs of
horror games
any any that come out i'm gonna keep
keep doing it
they're the only games i play on the
channel um
i will always take more where we will
clearly not get silent hill
i was so sure it was going to be like
the last thing because of what uh
guillermo del toro said
hello
my my
oh i take it back
it's very like the evil within
the tone of this trailer
makes me think it's also going to be a
pretty action heavy game
right
[Music]
like the music and just some of the the
cinematic things we saw there
oh my god
yeah i'm super down very very exciting
obviously we don't know a ton about it
based on that um but yeah uh
into it i'm gonna play it no matter what
which leads us into our next
survival horror alan wake two
we all come to a story with hopes and
expectations
looking for an answer
i love this shot
sometimes it would be better to live
with that
they're all good without ever finding
the story we're just getting to a point
where video games just
they look good man
this is not the story you want it to be
this story
will eat you alive
this story
is a monster she really looks like
bradley koopa and monsters wear many
faces
hell yeah why is it oh it includes the
interview with family
all right
what the hell jeff
um
yes didn't see that one coming it must
be awesome for keely and sam and remedy
that it didn't leak
um
i mean i guess we did see it coming but
i didn't know that it would definitely
have a trailer in the show or anything
um or if it did like maybe i just didn't
see it that happens a lot but yep
totally sold
uh
very curious to see what the gameplay is
like and i have this like ongoing beef
with alan wake where i dislike him as a
character because all he does is
complain and he's very broody and windy
in a way that like i found endearing
about max payne my camera's probably a
little bit too big sorry everyone um but
that i didn't like
in allen and wake and i wonder how they
will have will have shifted that kind of
thing because he was definitely going
for like the broody like self-loathing
writer trope that maybe now is a little
bit too played out i don't know it'll be
interesting to see um
curious to see what they do with
gameplay like are we still gonna have
the the double requirement with the
torch for
combat um
but yeah it being a survival horror
i don't know it's super exciting um
can't wait
and the last one i want to have a look
at um is
star wars eclipse
uh which
it sure is exciting when that's a weird
aspect ratio
just give me a normal one thank you um
when that lucasfilm logo pops up you're
like i'm sorry what
uh which was kind of my reaction
and yeah this is quantic
which is
the hype honestly the hype seeing this
like which is it going to be is this
going to be jedi fallen order 2 is what
i first thought
because that's going to be announced
surely any day now
um
was it gonna be the ubisoft thing
did not expect it to be
quantic dream who of course made detroit
become human heavy rain
um
beyond two souls
also looks fantastic that's
that's a lot of density look at all
those people
i actually think this is just a really
good
trailer
i don't love quantix games
but generally we'll play them um
they're short
and they're uh
easy to play not a huge investment
they could get pretty crazy with a star
wars license i guess
[Music]
[Music]
hard to see how much of the game will
actually look like this as well
but maybe this is it maybe we're like
all these trailers look so incredible
the reflections it is lighting all that
stuff looks so good maybe that is just
um
next-gen
we're finally actually seeing stuff come
out on
the new platforms
it's a really cool trailer um
[Music]
so unexpected
didn't see it coming
um so yeah those are the
the five big ones that i felt like i
wanted to rewatch but i'm wondering yeah
if i've forgotten anything um that that
happened during the show
let me know it yeah it wasn't uh wasn't
a ton of like huge reveals this year
um it's been a weird years you know a
lot of games
got delayed uh obviously because of
the whole global pandemic situation um
but i think these trailers do look
really really good and
i'm excited to see more i'm excited to
play some more video games um
yeah it was it was a fun time
and uh
let me know what you guys think
um i'd love to see any any extra shouts
or what you think of any of the trailers
i'm always down to chat about video
games so
uh that is it i will see you guys next
time bye